[Applause]
it's billed as one of the fastest sports
on snow with horses pulling skiers and
snowboarders around a course at speeds
of up to 65 km/h skijoring started in
Scandinavia combining cross-country
skiing and dog sledding but here in
Western Canada home to cowboys and trick
skiers it's all about the horsepower and
getting big air it's just about guts and
glory and going fast and having a good
horse that you can ride into battle
skeeter Canada started in 2017
since then competitions have drawn
medaled skiers trick riders and
championship cowboys and cowgirls
riders and sliders test their skills in
events such as circuits Sprint's relays
and the long jump winners take home a
few thousand dollars but nobody takes
the competition too seriously
we're hoping for the best of times we're
hoping to hop in our plywood truck that
we built and rip down that little strip
in front of all those people and
hopefully not die ski touring has come a
long way from its roots in Scandinavia
and organizers here say that it's now
the fastest growing winter sport in
North America
what started as a private event for a
dozen people four years ago now attracts
more than a hundred and fifty
competitors from across Canada in the
u.s. one of the crowd favorites came
from much further afield we have our
first ever Irish team competing at this
year's ski jordu they don't have snow in
Ireland so they've been practicing using
garbage bags and mud many of the 4,000
spectators came out to cheer on family
and friends and then there were those
who were curious to see how two very
different sports could be brought
together to come and see both discipline
together
Skeeter Canada is aiming to create a
national championship in the years to
come blending together a mountain
culture with the cowboy lifestyle in an
exhilarating sport that's hard to forget
David Mercer al Jazeera in Miller Ville
Canada